voyait pour par le nettoyage aujourd'hui
corinne la framboise et hygiéniste
dentaire avec toute la douleur quelque
chose qui va inquiéter au niveau des
dames enfilé des gants
corinne on a l'habitude cela s'entend
latex souple et fin pour rien je sentais
bien la main légère puis cnc sensible
mais d'autres fois ce sont des gants de
boxe qu'elle porte pour décrocher la
victoire
deux jours par semaine
corinne laframboise soulage les maux
dentaire 89e pour feindre pourquoi j'ai
ma job célibataire il y avait du talent
des patients auxquels elle ne peut
consacrer plus de temps jeu mais déjà un
20 25 par semaine d'entraînement puis je
suis capable de travailler deux jours et
demi par semaine
battus au quotidien corinne veut
intégrer la plus importante ligue
mondiale de combats d'arts martiaux
mixtes
l'ultimate fighting championship c'est
sûr et certain que je m'en vais à lui ai
fait mieux qu'un rêve
un objectif bien concret entre de
détartrage elle parcourt le monde et
glane les médailles
ce soir elle combat une championne
française otheka au de montréal et pour
ce combat
elle a fait appel à l'expertisé de
patrick côté un champion de l'ufc qui
totalisent plus d'une vingtaine de
victoire coréenne c'est un diamant qui
était bon groupe
ça je sais confiné à quelques plombs
elle connaît très très bien le jeu au
sol et la stap aux fines et son jeu
d'ensemble d'arts martiaux mixtes parce
que pour être avoir du succès dans ce
sport à la fois de plus complet passé
cette discipline spartiate ne l'effraie
pas elle mise sur ses forces
le dj dessous et la boxe thaï mais il
connaît tout aussi bien ses faiblesses
je sais que je serai jamais parfaite en
boxe a maintenant en faire de plus en
plus
et c'est chez les frères grande gloire
canadienne de la boxe qu'elle fait ses
classes
son entraîneur n'est autre qu à 2 grunts
un champion qui a aussi entraîné georges
st pierre
il veut regarder en premier mort c'était
détermine sa tente d'y aller
puis là après il faut choisir si messi
mais n'est pas aussi mais pas d'effort
les techniques sont tout le temps était
calme les compliments sont dur à aller
chercher mais
l'amp efficace et pourtant howard grant
ose même une comparaison avec jean saint
pierre
[Musique]
ces disciplines est pas sans danger le
dernier combat d'adonis t27 nous le
rappelle on sait que la clause comme
quoi que là bas
[Musique]
pour l'instant ils foncent au coût
qu'elle va donner et non à ce qu'elle va
recevoir son père venu l'encourager ne
cache pas sa crainte
généreux à toutes les fois le combat je
suis content de la voir mais j'ai mal au
ventre je suis stressée je n'ai robote
sceptre de ma fille un pareil c'est
comme ça je savais qu'il fallait qu'elle
se défouler un peu quand est un titre
des fois avec les directeurs nous
appelait parce qu'il y avait huit
l'action en cours avec elle c'est fait
exprès de l'huile entre les dents
élégant
corinne laframboise semble avoir trouvé
le juste équilibre et quelle que soit
l'issue du match de ce soir c'est sa
détermination qui triomphera ici as
micra gâte radio canada montréal